on the topic of sort of
uh the greater degrees of complexity
emerging
in consciousness i think few things
are as beautiful and inspiring as
taking a step outside of the human brain
just looking at systems
where simple rules create
incredible complexity uh not create
incredible complexity emerges so
one of the simplest things to do that
with is the cellular automata
and there's i don't know what it is and
maybe you can speak to it
we can certainly we will certainly talk
about the implications of this but
there's so few things that are as
awe-inspiring to me
as knowing the rules of a system and not
being able to predict what the heck it
looks like
and it creates incredibly beautiful
complexity
that when zoomed out on looks like
there's actual organisms doing things
that are much uh that operate on a scale
much higher than the underlying
mechanism so with cellular automata
that's cells that
are born and die born or die and they
only know about each other's neighbors
and they're simple rules that govern
that interaction of birth and death
and then they create at scale organisms
that
look like they take up hundreds or
thousands of cells
and they're moving they're moving around
they're communicating they're
sending signals to each other and you
forget
at moments at a time before you remember
that the simple rules on cells is all
that it took to create that
that's it's sad
in that we can't come up with a simple
description of that system
that generalizes the behavior of the
large organisms
we can only come up we can only hope to
come up with the thing the fundamental
physics
or the fundamental rules of that system
i suppose it's sad that we can't predict
everything we know about the mathematics
of those systems it seems like we can't
really in a nice way like economics
tries to do to predict how this whole
thing will unroll
but it's beautiful because how simple it
is underneath it all
so what do you make of the emergence of
complexity from simple rules
what the hell is that about yeah well we
can see that something like
flocking behavior the murmuration can
can be computer-coded it's not a very
hard set of rules to be able to see
some of those really amazing types of
complexity
and the whole field of complexity
science and some of the
sub disciplines like stigma g are are
studying how
following fairly simple responses to a
pheromone signal do ant colonies do this
amazing thing where the
what you might describe is the
organizational computational capacity of
the colony
is so profound relative to what each
individual
ant is doing i am not um anywhere near
as well versed
in the cutting edge of cellular automata
as i would like unfortunately i
in terms of topics that i would like to
get to and haven't like
uh et's more um wolfram's a new kind of
science i have only
skimmed and read reviews of and not read
the whole thing or his newer work since
um but his idea of the four
basic kind of categories of uh emergent
phenomena that can come from cellular
automata and that one of them is kind of
interesting and looks a lot
like complexity rather than just
chaos or homogeneity or
self-termination or whatever
i think this is very interesting
it does not instantly make me think that
uh biology
is operating on a similarly small set of
rules and or the human consciousnesses
i'm
i'm not that reductionistly oriented and
um so if you look at
say santa fe institute one of the
co-founders stuart kaufman
um his work he should you should really
get him on your show so
a lot of the questions that you like one
of kauffman's in a more recent books
after investigations and some of the
real fundamental stuff was called
reinventing the sacred and it had to do
with some of these exact questions
uh in kind of non-reductionist approach
but that is not
just silly hippie-ism and he was very
interested in highly
non-ergotic systems where you couldn't
take a lot of behavior over a small
period of time and predict what the
behavior of
subsets over a longer period of time
would do um
and then going further someone who spent
some time at santa fe institute and then
kind of made a whole new field that you
should have on
dave snowden who some people call the
father of anthrocomplexity or what is
the complexity unique to humans
he says something to the effect of that
modeling humans as termites really
doesn't
cut it like we we don't respond exactly
identically to
the same pheromone stimulus using stigma
g like it works for flows of traffic and
some very simple human
behaviors but it really doesn't work for
trying to make sense of the sistine
chapel and picasso and general
relativity creation and stuff like that
and it's because the the termites are
not doing abstraction
forecasting deep into the future and
making choices now based on forecasts of
the future not just adaptive signals in
the moment an evolutionary code from
history
that's really different right like
making choices now that can factor deep
modeling of the future
and with humans our uniqueness one to
the next
in terms of response to similar stimuli
is much higher than it is with a termite
one of the interesting things there is
that their uniqueness is extremely low
they're basically fungible within a
class
right there's different classes but
within a class they're basically
fungible and their system
uses that very high numbers and lots of
um loss right like that the termite
feels that way
don't you think we humans are deceiving
ourselves about our uniqueness perhaps
it doesn't just isn't there some sense
in which this emergence just creates
different
higher and higher levels of abstraction
where every at every layer
each organism feels unique is that
possible
that we're all equally dumb but at
different scales no i think uniqueness
is evolving
i think that hydrogen atoms are more
similar to each other
than cells of the same type are and i
think that cells are more similar to
each other than humans are
i think that highly k-selected species
are more unique than our selected
species so they're different
evolutionary processes
they are selected species where you have
a whole a lot of death
and very high birth rates you're not
looking for as
much individuality within
or individual possible expression to
cover the evolutionary search space
within an
individual you're looking at it more in
terms of a numbers game
so yeah i would say there's probably
more difference between one orca and the
next than there is between one cape
buffalo and the next
you